active assist recommenders can help
proactively uncover a lot of
opportunities to improve things
including the performance of your cloud
workloads
imagine this scenario you've got a web
server and an application server each
hosted on compute engine virtual
machines an update to the application
server was rolled out two weeks ago that
added a bunch of new features
since then there's been an uptick in the
number of timeout errors on the web
server when it attempts to communicate
with the application server
it seems that performance has been
compromised and it's starting to affect
the business
how can you avoid this scenario from
happening in the first place one way is
by keeping an eye out for opportunities
to improve performance let's see how
activeassist can assist you with that
it's not always easy to figure out what
could be causing performance issues and
how you can improve the situation when
it comes to compute engine instances an
ideal place to start is making sure that
you're using the correct machine types
for your workloads in the previous video
we talked about how the vm machine type
recommender can help you reduce costs by
offering right sizing recommendations
remember applying right sizing
recommendations that resize your vm to a
smaller machine type will let you avoid
wasted resources and optimize for costs
however when resource constraints are
detected inside of your vm rightsizing
recommendations to resize to a larger
machine type will optimize for
performance
the vm machine type recommender will
recommend a larger machine type when it
identifies a vm that is persistently
throttled by insufficient resources such
as cpu or memory
here an n2 high cpu 32 offers a better
fit for the memory used as well as
offering the cpus that are actually
needed to run the workload
in our scenario from the start of this
video this very well might have resolved
those performance issues these
recommendations are created by analyzing
data from cloud monitoring over the past
8 days
compute engine offers a number of
standard machine types with fixed cpu
and memory amounts
if none of those fit the requirements
identified by a recommender a custom
machine type might be offered with
appropriate amounts of cpu in memory
right sizing recommendations aren't just
limited to single instances either you
can also receive right sizing
recommendations for vms in a managed
instance group
these recommendations will come from the
appropriately named managed instance
group machine type recommender but they
work very much like the single instance
recommendations this is especially
useful for cases where you may not be
able to increase the size of the
instance group or for workloads that
just don't work well with auto scaling
for managed instance groups metrics are
collected and analyzed from all of the
instances in the group that way the
recommendation won't undersize for any
of the individual instances
as always you know your workload's best
when you receive those recommendations
you can choose to review and apply them
or just dismiss them and hide them from
the cloud console you can always view
them in the history page of the
recommendation hub
beyond just virtual machines there's a
few recommenders that can help you
maintain or improve performance of other
cloud resources
for example if you're using cloud sql
you can receive recommendations from the
cloud sql out of disk recommender
these recommendations come from looking
at the disk space usage of a cloud sql
instance
by analyzing the storage utilization
trends over the last 30 days
recommendations can be generated if an
instance is likely to run out of space
the recommendations will suggest either
manually increasing storage capacity
enabling the ability to automatically
increase storage or deleting data to
free up disk space
activisus can help you be proactive and
avoid downtime or performance issues
that could be caused by running out of
disk space on your cloud sql instances
performance issues can be tricky to deal
with the recommenders we've looked at
today can help you stay on top of
performance issues by analyzing usage
data and suggesting ways to fix resource
constraints you can check out the
documentation to try these out for
yourself and don't forget about the
recommendation hub where you can see all
sorts of helpful recommendations stay
tuned for the next video where we'll
look at some more recommendations that
will focus around strengthening security
in your cloud environment see you there
you